lady ballers in which I have a very
small Cameo has absolutely crushed it in
terms of viewership and box office
earnings it's daily wire's biggest
launch ever so it's got 97% of Rotten
Tomatoes it's got two critic reviews one
positive one extremely negative but my
favorite one was from a lib I think it
was actually Hanan he said that
lady Ballers is like Mrs Doubtfire but
evil and the funniest thing about this
review the ironic thing about this
review is that it reminded me that Mrs
Doubtfire itself is evil because Mrs
Doubtfire promotes divorce it was just
Peak 90s entertainment I think it may
have come out actually in ' 89 that was
just the vibe of the 1990s I like the
comparison to Mrs Doubtfire because it
was crossdressing and it's funny I guess
you would just say though lady Ballers
is like Mrs Doubtfire but good